you can see declared by the governor as
a result of the clover 19 pandemic
and according to house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
executive order 2020 nashua iv
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing of bills
referred to the ways and means
executive session on pending legislation
may be held
please note that there's no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporariously to this
meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporariously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaries listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies the
house rsa
91a anyone who has a problem access
needs to call 271 3600
or email hcs lake.state.nh dot us
event the public is unable to access the
meeting the meeting will be adjourned
and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting to assist us
jennifer iv committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting should be done
by roll call votes
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone
in the room when you're during this
meeting which is required
under the right to know law
representative bernstein i want to thank
you all
thank you mr chair and good morning to
you and good morning to everyone
good morning it's march 16 2021
903 am we'll begin roll call with
representative patrick abrami
my wife's in the house representative
mary griffin
representative jordan owerry mary's here
mary's here you gotta tell her how to uh
uh star sex
mary to unmute
started sick this is mary griffin and
i'm
i'm here and i'm alone in my home in
windham
it is great to hear your voice good
morning thank you very much
representative hillary i'm here the wife
is in the house someplace in hudson
representative ober
erin hudson with the six cats
representative fred doucette
good morning all uh here in my home
office in salem alone
your clerk is alan bershken i'm here in
my home office in beautiful nottingham
new hampshire
by myself representative elliott i'm
here in salem new hampshire and my wife
is in the living room
good morning representative jeanigan
yes i'm here in salem new hampshire and
my wife is in the house
good morning and jeanigan did i get that
right perfect
thank you representative nunes
good morning mr clerk i'm home alone in
pelham
good morning representative tim baxter
good morning mr clerk and i'm home alone
as well
representative spillsbury good morning
home in charlestown alone for now
good morning representative paul tudor
good morning representative army number
one in lebanon
representative richard ames i'm home
alone and
uh jeffrey representative southworth
home alone in dover representative
dennis malloy
representative malloy representative
schamberg
i'm in my office in wilmington my wife's
in her office
thank you hey you're actually in your
office it's good to be here
oh that's good
representative tucker i'm home alone in
randolph
good morning representative gomarlo
i'm home alone in swansea
representative laughman
representative tomloff representative
gorg
representative mary hacken phillips
morning
i come to you alone for my office in
concord good morning
representative james murphy good morning
i am home alone
in hanover and our chair representative
norman major
good morning in my office in pasta my
wife is in the house
and i got an email from dennis malloy
he's gonna try to join at nine via
telephone
so we'll be looking for a telephone
symbol for representative malloy
there is a phone uh ending in 827
over in the attendees i have no way of
knowing if
how do they raise their hand if they're
star nine
yes star nine so if you're dennis malloy
raise your hand by pressing star nine
okay mr chair there are 21 members
present three are not present
mr chairman
i was told that on representative gorg
will be
a whale this week i'm sorry if she
didn't tell you to
what was the phone numbers last four
digits eight
two seven yeah i think that's dennis
okay uh
hmm
gen 4 i can't promote him to panelists
for some reason
i'll send her a text too
as an attendee he should be able to hear
us anyway right
yes and i can allow him to to speak as
well
okay but there's a way to do it because
mary's
um been promoted so gen 4 must
be able to do that okay
all right we have any bills this morning
the first two bills
have the same title uh i'm going to do a
house
uh senate bill 22-fn
first followed by senate bill
number 27. i'm going to build
22 fm relative to the sale of lucky
seven tickets
and
i'm sponsored senator french senator
france has
signed in in support but he will not be
testifying
uh senator reagan hennessey gannon
senator reagan is in support
as a co-sponsor is not testifying
senator hennessey is in support not
testifying
and who is testifying as a
tyler clark who's a lobbyist
that's tyler uh do you need someone to
introduce to bill more
we introduce first
want me to introduce it looks like
senator guide is on the call i don't
know if he's there pat
oh i didn't realize that sorry he's not
on 22 has a sponsor but
he's on the next he's the next bell yeah
whatever you'd like to
then if senator geider is here
why don't we go right to 27
mr chairman so we're not going to listen
to
the lobbyist we will but we're going to
come back for that
since senator geider is here we're going
to go to senate bill
27 that's also relative to the sale of
lucky seven tickets
and senator geider is the prime and only
sponsor of this bill
so senator geider
thank you mr chairman uh am i loud and
clear this morning
thank you it's a pleasure to be here
before this uh in committee
uh as prime sponsor of senate bill 27
for the record
uh senator bob guida representing the 27
towns of district 2
uh and chairman of the ways and means in
the senate
this is a bill that's primarily a
housekeeping bill
from the requested by
the commission and
accordingly i'll go through the
different parts of the bill part one
changes the term of a charity gaming
license from 12 months from issue
to annually expiring at the end of each
calendar year again that
will make housekeeping and managing
the licensure uh much easier for
uh the again a lot of the gaming
commission
uh part two expands the definition of
charitable organizations for the
purposes of issuing charitable gaming
bingo and lucky seven
licenses um it really
doesn't expand what it does is it
incorporates all of the gaming
uh there are two types basically 27d
um i'm sorry 287d
and 287e uh one deals with lucky seven
and bingo
the other deals with poker games and
what we'll do is
is standardize the language between the
two
uh in that sense it is an expansion
because
an organization would have to put in for
one type of license but wouldn't be
qualified for another
they'd have to go after the other
license separately again it's it is a
request of the department
uh part three uh corrects incorrect
references
to the lottery commission uh where
instead it was supposed to be referring
to the commission paid
uh on each dollar so incorrectly the
lottery had
gotten its way in there i don't know
whether it was a word processing issue
or some other error but that corrects
that
problem uh and then the
roman four changes the definition of the
deal
in references to lucky seven again
requested by the
the lottery people and uh happy to
answer any questions
questions for senator geider
representative
representative muted
thank you mr chairman uh senator guida
i'm a little confused because i
think that your definition of the deal
contradicts the 1 in 22
and it and some of this
also overlaps with on
i believe it's 25.
uh why weren't all of these just
in one bill uh i
i can't answer that man uh vice chair i
have
uh only again i i deal with the bills
that i sponsor
uh as far as amalgamating them into one
bill uh
again prime pearson has the right to
sponsor a bill and that's i think that's
the way they came through the
we process look to our esteemed
colleagues in the house perhaps to
remedy those
and if i could have a follow-up
follow-up
references in section two then
are things that are already in one
statute or another but we're just
combining them into the same one that's
correct
thank you does this mean that
uh bingo has been been reducing
into a a small corner of the charitable
gaming
world when it used to be the charitable
gaming world back in the
fire department days on does
this make it pretty much sure that
there's
only occasionally going to be a game of
bingo
in the very back of a large hall of
machines and and
poker yeah i i'm not sure what it will
mean in terms of those parameters
representative again we are what we're
trying to do
is to standardize the language between
uh
and simplify the process for the
charitable organizations
that are requesting licenses as far as
the you know
what will be the end result i'm not sure
uh i'm not sure anybody can be sure of
what it will produce
we have charlie mcintyre and the
attendees
and janine you may want to uh
bring him in and i'm sure that'll be a
good question for charlie
thank you i promoted him and
valerie king has her hand up as well
and valerie is his partner right
so why don't you promote her too
are we are we done asking questions uh
representative ames for the next
question yeah and uh i have three quick
questions
and uh if santa guy thinks they're
better answered by
uh director mcintyre that would be fine
so on the first page of the bill
you're changing the the bill changes
the registration with the secretary of
state
requirement to having been registered
for at least
one year uh changing from a two-year
requirement
do you know why that change is being
made
i would defer to the department
okay the second i'm sorry charlie could
answer that
charlie actually uh valerie if you would
for us sorry enough to keep asking along
but valerie if you're on
yeah um the change from two years to one
year was actually
something that was proposed by someone
outside of the agency
we just wanted the language the
definitions of a charitable game
charitable organization to match so that
we can vet this
an organization once rather than twice
um but the one the two to one year was
um
recommended or suggested from somebody
outside the agency
all right um so i go on
chair major right
um the second question is uh
on the same page in the uh
to be eligible for licensure under this
charity
chapter a charitable
shall do all of all of the following
then you've got a list one two three and
four all of this is new
and the fourth one is maintain a current
list of bona fiding members
i know and i'm sure all of you know that
many charities don't have members are
not
membership organizations and
i guess i assume i don't know for sure
that
non-membership charitable organizations
participate in
charitable gaming so
my question is isn't that what i just
said true and why this additional
requirement
can either charlie or valerie answer
that
well is this your language this is the
language
that was originally in um one of the
statutes again we're just trying to
match them so we can vet
the the charity once for all game types
um generally if there
is just a single member
like there's got to be somebody so that
member list would probably have one
person on it
it's mostly our member list is primarily
so that we know
um who is authorized
to do certain activities
okay i think there's a membership uh a
drafting issue there
okay so representative names your
appointment members or officers or the
equivalent of
i know that that sounds like what you
want to get at but that's
if you want to say that you need to say
that because uh
members bona fide members to
get the entire phrase out
is a term that has meaning um
legally and uh yeah i think you need to
be
uh the language needs to be different
there are membership
organizations just to throw one out
that's uh a national one
is the sierra club is a membership
charity
and uh planned parenthood to take
another example is not
uh and so forth charlie and valerie is
that something you can look into
and get resolved i just just want to
just clarify one thing one of the
reasons why we need the members list
is for certain games like bingo and
lucky seven
only bona fide members are allowed to
participate in the operation of the
games and so that's what we would use
the list for
sorry
[Music]
um you also represent ames
no i got a third one go ahead um
on the uh this may be an easier one
for the lottery um
on the deal definition which is on page
three at the bottom
um there's the
this new definition instead of being a
box or bag
[Music]
the deal becomes a quote single game
of uncirculated lucky seven tickets
and that
begs the question at least to me what is
a single game
uh can you answer that
so a single game of deals of lucky
sevens
is a set number of tickets um
it can be from currently we have any
anywhere up to 3 500 tickets makes a
deal that's a single game
there are so many winners and so many
losers in that deal
so whether it comes in a box or a bag is
irrelevant what a deal is and if you
look at definitions
from other states on how they define a
deal it's
that set game with a certain number of
winners and losers within that set
number of tickets
okay i'll take that away and chew on it
i don't have any other questions
you're all set representatives i am
okay uh representative romney followed
by tucker
and albany representative brown yeah
thank you mr chair
um i guess this question will be for the
lottery
uh but it appears and this is a
follow-up to represent
ames discussion about who's eligible
and obviously the here we go again with
the list of
internal revenue sections codes it
appears that there are six
you have to have one of those codes to
be eligible as a charity
which is consistent if you go to page
two in two spots
it looks like they just move that around
those six
exist but they're crossed out because i
guess we moved it to this section
and then uh that would be line nine
uh eight nine on page two and then again
line uh line
18 on page two across out because they
move
that so it doesn't look like we've we've
added or deleted any
uh codes that would make someone
eligible a charity eligible
although i think what representative
ames is saying and
uh representative ames please chime in
and correct me if i'm wrong
is that now that you look at those codes
that
there may be other internal revenue
codes
of organizations that actually
[Music]
are already uh participating in
charitable gaming
so maybe maybe i can ask dick if that's
correct
and then then have charlie respond
yeah i got it yeah um
that i don't i don't know i i i don't
know
the full extent of each of these irc
sections um and uh
as you point out i think i haven't
looked at it closely but i don't think
there's any change in the list
no i didn't there isn't yeah you did
yeah um
so it's really a different point that uh
is the use of the word members as a
mandatory
um part of what a
an organization is supposed to
provide um as documentation
to the um to the lottery i guess
it's supposed to maintain a current list
of bona fide a members
i don't know what that means and i think
the
statutory language should be a little
more complete particularly since you've
got this
i'd say confusion or
this other source of authority for
charities that
that uses the concept of membership in a
different way
okay can charlie react to that uh mr
chair
yeah of course certainly um i think
representative ames brings up a good
point is the
the what is sentence for of that section
related to bona fide members and can be
worked on but otherwise there'd be no
changes to it
from where we would see it yeah that's
fine
thank you almost mr chair thank you
uh zen tucker yes uh
i think we've all missed representative
griffin i want to make sure
that she is satisfied with the language
as presented
and i count on her for
her special knowledge could she comment
police
about how she's viewing this
maybe she needs reminding about how to
you
are unmuted representative griffin you
hit star six again yep there you go
one more time
uh star six to unmute mary
thank you and yes i am following i'm
really very closely attuned to what's
going on
in the gambling i i i'm following it
along and i'm not having a problem at
the moment
i just want to make sure that you're
happy uh
well i'll be happy if i if it comes out
the way that i want it to be yes
may i just remind you to to hit star
nine to raise your hand
yes i will do that thank you dear we'll
see that thank you
okay representative ellen
thank you mr chairman on i'm not sure
that representative griffin has seen the
bill
yet uh she hadn't yesterday
uh so um i would like
to ask about two things one of them
is we retained another bill because
we were unclear about what's
in all of these irc codes
and wanted to think about it more this
summer
and bundling everything together at this
point
so that it covers all of
bingo and charitable gaming on is
something i think
needs to be more we need to look at this
language very carefully
across all of the provisions that
that are here and
that's dealing with
with the sections one to four part
and and on
and on i'm not
sure myself about this one to two years
to have a bona fide charity that and
what is involved in being actually
registered with the
secretary um the secretary of state or
is it
charitable um
secretary of state um
anybody can register anything with the
secretary of state
and not on and it doesn't really do
anything except that they're supposed to
send you a postcard in five years to ask
if you still exist
i don't question representatives yeah i
don't
i don't really understand if there is
any
on if it is registered with the
ag's charitable or um
charitable division that's one thing but
if it's registered with the secretary of
state
that seems like an extremely i could
register
as a temple of worship tomorrow
and they wouldn't notice what was going
on
at least that's the way it has been and
the
the final thing that i wanted
to look at was um
section five the definition of a deal
is on the 300
500 limit still
in law somewhere if that gets
changed the way it is there thank you
you have a question that was the
question uh
the rest of it was a comment mr terry if
i may
send a guy i mean senator geiger thank
you very much
um on the issue of the charitable
organizations
i have a list it's very specific as to
what those are i'd be happy to provide
it
to the committee i can read it to you
now if you're interested it won't take
long
501c3 is a charity organization
501c4 social welfare organizations such
as a housing association
501c7 is fraternities and social clubs
501c8 is fraternal benefit societies
that provide various types of insurance
to members
501c10 is fraternal organizations such
as the moose club
and 501c19 are veterans organizations
so those would be as defined in the in
the
the the dark language in section number
um or is it section number
yes and um
as far as the deal the 3500 is defined
in statute at present
there is some legislation that is moving
forward to change that number
but at president is statutorily defined
as 3500.
thank you mr chairman could i um
point out to senator guida that
501c4 is also the code for
all political pacs
political action committees
fine um
i think we need to go on
next is representative hacken phillips
mr chair uh i just wanted to pick up on
what representative ames was stating
before in regards to some
non-profit charities that when they
become
formed have the option to select formal
membership
or no formal membership in the original
formation process at the secretary of
state's office
there are many educational medical
scientific society
um type nonprofit organizations that
select
not to have formal membership or
employees and to strictly function
as a public good so they do not have
formal membership
in that formation process therefore they
would not qualify under this definition
for that bona fide membership as it
stands here
in my legal opinion um so
my concern is that you know you would be
excluding several very worthy charitable
organizations
just from this change and i would you
know bring that to your attention and
just ask you
you know why you would intend to exclude
those important organizations as well
you want to respond either senator
geider
or valerie or i think there's certainly
no intent to exclude anyone
and i i would welcome any change to that
uh
that uh part of this legislation that's
proposed i'd certainly welcome a change
that makes it more inclusive uh and
uh enables such organizations uh if they
so desire to participate
valerie do you have anything to add to
that
yeah i just wanted to point out that a
bona fide member
is defined in the in the statute
under the definition section also it's
referred throughout the statute
so if you do make a change you're going
to have to make changes throughout
again the intent is we need to know who
is authorized to participate because
the statute for lucky seven and
bingo limit who can actually
operate the games to bona fide members
so
it would require a significant change to
the statute
charlie did you have anything to add no
no that was what i was going to suggest
as well is that um we have defined that
already
and we need to make changes through the
law if we change it here as well
okay are you all set representative
at consultants
all right and we'll go to uh
representative romney
thank you mr chair um back to the whole
issue of the secretary of state
uh being registered with the secretary
of state that's incurred statute there's
nothing changed there
so my question for charlie um
mcintyre is how does that process work
uh charity wants to get involved the
does the lottery commission get involved
double check that they're also
registered with the secretary of state
or does can you
just uh clarify that for me yeah we do
um certainly uh valerie does check with
the secretary of state's office to
confirm that they've been
registered with there for the past two
years um
and that there is a process by which
they do disclose information the center
states office val if you want to
elaborate on that
yeah we can actually go on the secretary
of state's website
to confirm and we do especially if we
have the number
the registration number we can easily
confirm that they're still in good
standing with secretary of state
if we have any questions we can also
reach out to the secretary of state to
confirm
okay thank you again it's nothing new
this is
this is current statute um thank you
okay uh representative
uh you're muted susan
susan you're muted i know it's very
difficult
uh sometimes to get my laptop to unmute
um even
on could we when before we finish
dealing with this bill
talk to the secretary of state's
registration
office about how they're handling these
now because
it used to be that you would just walk
in and fill out a form
and you were all of a sudden the company
or or i don't know whether there's a
separate one
for charitable organizations
but there was no follow-up
at all and
and we've had cases on the condominium
side that i i work on where
on people would register and
unregister as condominium or homeowner
organizations
on at will without on
without the board of these of the
organization knowing it had been done
and and um
[Music]
we're or without the the people in the
association knowing that they were an
association
so i would like to have a conversation
with the secretary of state's office to
see whether this actually means anything
we can arrange to have somebody from the
secretary of state
thank you uh work session
um
represent ames
thank you um just this is just a quick
comment
uh that um
i think first there's confusion because
we've got several
bills before us this morning
uh dealing with the same subject and
overlapping and we've got two of them
right in this
hearing space right now but there's
two others that deal with uh lucky seven
or games of chance um and we're going to
have to put them together i mean it
doesn't make any sense
what we've got before us right now uh so
that's a task ahead of us i think
and then on this question of membership
i think it's all i want to say is i
think it's easily resolved
um and the uh the phrase
maintain a current list of bona fide
members
shouldn't be in the eligibility section
which is where it is right now there
should be a separate requirement if
if there should be such a requirement
i'll take that as
as given since that's what you require
now
and and say separately that
in the appropriate place that a
charitable organization
uh participating in uh this
process uh shall maintain a list of
bona fide members as defined in such and
such
section of the statute that sort of
takes care
of the problem since it is a defined
term as
has been pointed out so uh that's all i
had to say that's a comment not a
question
all right uh valerie you rub your hand
up
valerie do you have anything else yes
i um i just wanted to have two things
um representative ames makes a good
point i just want to make sure that if
you remove it from one you remove it
from both
because the the whole point of this
proposed
language is so that they match each
other between lucky seven and
games of chance bingo the other thing i
just wanted to let uh representative all
me know that
the reason why we use secretary of state
is more for
making sure that they've been in in
existence and are a new
uh you know their they're they can do
business in new hampshire
so that's that's mostly what we use
secretary of state for is just to
confirm that they are a new hampshire
business and registered to to do
business in new hampshire
and that they've been in existence for
two years
okay for one year
but there's one more uh
representative elliott
bob you're muted
all right it's for this is uh for
valerie
uh king did you say that
quote a bona fide member unquote
is in the bill
bona fide member is already uh defined
in statute under rsa
287 e1 roman numeral
two um uh roman numeral three
so that's in the statute already it's
not part of the bill
so it's already in the bill thank you
very much
okay since saying no other hands i'm
going to ask senator geider
what's the primary difference between
house bill 20 i mean senate bill 27
and senate bill 22
uh that's an excellent question mr
chairman and at this point i
i i'd have to get back to you on that
okay
i have one other person signed up to
speak on this
and that is rick newman and i think he's
in attendance
so janine could you bring him in
rick newman is a lobbyist from the
grover gaming
in support of the bill
and i notice it says zero minutes so
that means
it doesn't want to speak there
well i've promoted him he's muted
um i'm not sure if he wants to speak or
not
rick newman do you want to speak on this
bill yes mr chairman i'm sorry the
my screen changed i think it was because
of the way i was brought in
thank you mr chairman um my name is rick
newman
and representing new hampshire
charitable gaming operators association
on senate bill 27 i will be brief
uh i did just want to say that um for
instance uh
section one section one is a change to
go
back to what it used to be it used to be
that
in games of chance poker rooms um
the licenses for charities were good
until december 31st
a few years ago that was changed to make
them
uh run for 12 months and that's caused a
lot of confusion
with uh you know the people who licensed
charities in the rooms and with the
lottery so we feel that's a an excellent
change to re
return to what used to be um
that that really is a housekeeping
measure uh but it will uh
save a lot of headaches for a lot of
people
um section two the uh
the the various 501 c3s uh senator gaida
went through those
um my understanding is all that's
happening there
is that currently though that list
exists
in 287e the bingo statute
and it's now being replicated in 287d
uh the games of chance poker room statue
again to make it uh the same between
both statutes
um i'd like the issue of the
uh deal uh definition um
this was something that the
administrative rules committee asked for
about four years ago
maybe later that this be addressed
because the
current deal definition is simply
outdated it says bag or box
and that's not the way deals of lucky
sevens
really come exclusively anymore and so
that
deal definition doesn't have any
implications beyond the fact that
it is recognizing that the
uh the this new deal language will in
fact comport to what is happening in the
in the marketplace um
and and the issue about the membership
to representative ames
issue um i i do know perhaps
ms king can address this i know that
currently there are
charities for instance i've run into it
with
uh little leagues uh where you don't
really have a member
uh but there are little leagues that
participate in charity gaming
and i think they've accommodated that in
some ways by
uh i think in the case of little leagues
for instance they have
uh they use the parents of the kids who
participate
uh but that language bona fide members
is in the current 2017
it looks new because it's being added to
287d
again for the reason to just have the
same language in both statutes
um but it's really it's not new
and one final point uh to representative
almey's point about
uh how easy it is to register at
secretary of state and that's absolutely
accurate
um but i would point out that it's not
just registering with secretary of state
that makes a charity eligible um you
also have to be the charities so you
have to be
you know uh registered under one of
these 501 c
threes and have a letter from the irs
acknowledging that
uh and then in addition to that you
register with the secretary of state new
hampshire
to as ms king pointed out to demonstrate
that you are a new hampshire-based
charity with that mr chairman i
conclude my testimony we do support this
bill this morning mr newman
we take questions i will uh
representative early
thank you it's uh i was having a hard
time getting uh
onto the internet for some reason or
another
at any rate uh regarding membership
lists etc the knights of columbus
particularly down in salem
uh do a large amount of uh fundraising
using gaming lists of memberships are
not
possible from a 501c8 such as the
knights of columbus
um that's going to be a bit of a problem
and then in addition your uh
comprehensive list that
senator geider read out did not include
the masons
and the masons are engaged in gaming
they're 501 c
10. um they're
sometimes making a laundry list of who
can participate and who can't
um creates issues uh
there's some problems with both of these
bills
in trying to clarify they've actually
muddied the waters
as far as i see so far excuse me i got a
frog on my throat
but i i would point out i agree with you
representative ulri
of 501c10s are listed and the masons are
one of those groups or a number of
groups i don't think
um every one of them was was mentioned
but
yes a 501 c 10 would include a masons
the knights of columbus
several other types of organizations
that come under that
um that is on current law as i
understand and it is currently
the list that exists in rsa287e
and it's simply by this bill being uh
added to 287d
for the purposes of making both statutes
the same
yes i i understand that uh mr newman
but the uh the situation is when you
start
asking for lists of members you're
getting into
uh territory where you're asking for uh
uh
confidential information people join uh
or
the masons are much more secret than the
knights are
now at this point but their membership
lists are not public
ours are not public there's been
incidents uh
where publicly have been made are being
privately
been made public uh either through uh
uh hacking operations or inattention of
uh
bureaucracies i hate to say that to you
charlie but
your bureaucracy um
that's a bit of an issue for uh the
knights of columbus
is getting involved with registering
with the secretary
of state and or the uh
charitable um division and i agree the
secretary of state doesn't fall through
it much
unless you know our corporation and they
want their money every
april okay
rep senator brownlee uh yes thank you mr
chair uh
mr newman um when it comes to this
current statutes to forget about these
this this bill
is there any provision for exceptions to
the rule
uh that that you're aware of and i'll
ask the same question of
of uh miss king or uh or charlie
mcintyre
as well well i i know for instance and
i'm sure valerie answered this better
but i do know for instance the tilted
little league is one
where you don't have members per se but
i know they participate in charities
uh charity gaming so um i
i guess the answer is they must have
some provisions where they allow
uh you know so-called non-member
charities
uh to participate they must give them i
believe with the case of little leagues
they give the parents
list but i defer to valerie
um as far as who's considered a member
we basically we feel that the charity
determines
what makes somebody eligible for
membership i mean
the statute does say they have to be a
member for at least 60 days but it's
really the
charities criteria on what they consider
membership to be
so we don't go any deeper than
them providing a list of who they
consider their members to be so that we
can confirm that only those
individuals are participating in the
operations
but follow up mr chair
so valerie um so but they would have to
there's no exception to the ir internal
revenue codes that are here so
are we saying that little league falls
in one of these irs codes
we have had little leagues as charitable
organizations so i assume
that they do i'm not sure which one okay
thank you i'm set mr chair
representing names
thank you um so uh
mr newman the question is the first
question is
uh whether you know why the move from
two years to one year
for the registration requirement
i'm sorry i don't i remember that
somebody
i ran into that problem and i i honestly
don't recall who it was i don't recall
who
asked for that okay so far we've got a
change that nobody can explain
um so that's that's just a comment um
and in terms of this membership issue
i'm thinking of a local charity that's
here in
jeffrey and in the monadnock region
that's called monadnock at home that's a
wonderful charity serving
homeless people it's not a membership
organization i don't think they'd
know what to say if you asked who are
your members i know they
they considered they do not
participate but they considered
participating in charitable games as a
way of
maybe raising some money and have chosen
not to but if they
chose to pursue it i think they'd be
confounded by this
way as presented now in this bill as a
prerequisite for being eligible
and maybe you comment on on that problem
yeah no i i totally can understand that
and i think um
accommodations should be made there are
probably a lot of charities that fall
into that
um the only thing i can say is that you
know 287 e requires the list of
charities for the reasons that valerie
has said which is
that in that case only charities can
operate bingo
um 287d of course is different because
games of chance poker rooms
are operated by game operators so that
charity operation requirement is not in
that statute
um and i i i totally agree with you i
think that's probably something that
needs to be dealt with
so just to comment on in response my
takeaway is that
we just need to be careful here we need
to make sure that
we're not unintentionally excluding
organizations that should be excluded i
think the challenge is to look at the
both the the references to the federal
uh categories for a charitable
organization make sure that we've got
got that down right and then use the
concept of membership carefully
okay um
representative romney followed by
representing yours
thank you mr chair this is a question
for charlie mcintyre
have you given any thought to uh
expanding the list of of uh
codes here or or a mechanism to
formally do exemptions to that list to
include other
charities we have we have actually to
appoint representative abrami we have
uh we receive requests from charities
that are registered with a charitable
trust division of the ag's office but
not registered secretary of state's
office
and um so the answer is yes so
if if possible
mr chairman major if we could look at
the language and
respond to it in kind um i think we can
clean this up
with a re-drafting if that makes sense
to you
we don't have to just go out for a while
so we'll have the time to do that
okay so certainly to address that
question as well as
represent representative ames issue
regarding membership which is
i think we've been doing the work around
here in terms of what qualifies as
membership but
to further refine it is probably a good
idea going forward
so i i think by
checking with the secretary of state's
office and the attorney general's office
bringing those types of charities
together so everybody's
voted if you can solve that that's going
to help
yes yes sir all right uh
representative early
thank you mr chair and as a suggestion
uh from
from what miss king had just uh stated
you don't really want a list of members
you just want a list of contact persons
so having just a list of contact persons
using languages to
quote-unquote authorized persons
is what you're looking for is that
correct
you want to respond to that valerie or
kali
yeah that's that's essentially correct
and whether
as as uh as has been mentioned earlier
if you if it were removed from the
statute as a requirement that would be
fine because we can still require in
rules that they provide us with the list
of people that are
um authorized to participate
yeah very good
just to follow up on that mr chair yes
the problem with that is uh
authorized to participate well what do
you mean participate
because uh for example bishop guertin
runs bingo at one of the halls to
collect money for
uh bishop guertin and that rotates
amongst the parents
so
who's so who's an authorized person
it's like representative ames comment
about
his his local uh uh uh charity up there
for the town i mean we're we're getting
into
i think we've beaten this to death we
know what the issue is
it needs to be worked out with a
solution
and let's wait for that solution thank
you sir
anything new uh representative
elementary
representation you're muted
thank you um i
um did want to bring up something that
we haven't discussed yet
on hey on the first page
line 16-17
what does it mean or is covered under a
group
ruling issued by the internal revenue
service under the authority of those
sections on
would that mean that um anybody who
wanted to create a scam charity
could um register themselves
on with you on saying
that you were a little league or
something like that
on in a small town
uh that um and
do you use these this language and
and how do you use this language
this is to valerie or charlie
um so the the group ruling is really
just
it's they have their irs
um their non-profit status is
under a an umbrella so like
miss america may be the the head one but
they have all these
other local miss americas so those
little ones are under the big one that's
it's just uh an affiliation okay
so if the new hampshire guns of america
firm whatever that thing is called guns
for america or every town
gun sense on the new hampshire
group if they've got a c4
then the new hampshire group would be
considered under
their original irs license that's all
that means
right okay thank you we've
spent a long a lot of time on this we're
going to have a work session
and people are going to come back with
some solutions
so anything else if not i'm closing
i don't see any other hand closing the
public area on
senate bill 27 and just go back to
senate bill
22. senate bill 22
has the same title it's um
but
it just has
three looks like small sections but
a small section could be really big
so i'm going to go into the public
hearing on house bill
on senate bill 22
it's on a bill 22
to testify
we have taylor uh
he's opposed four o'clock uh
mark do you want me to introduce the
bill
let's introduce the bill what's up
no one has to introduce the bill all
right okay
okay so we don't have a sponsor here
so you won't want to introduce the bill
yeah
i will thank you thank you mr chair uh
patrami
uh rockham 19 stratum
i'm here to introduce house bill 22 uh
relative to the sale of
lucky seven tickets uh and will not take
questions
thank you okay we have two people
signed up
one to support the bill and one to
oppose
and they're both lobbyists so
rick newman's here rick
you wanted to testify in support of
representative schamberg has a question
before anybody okay representative
sandberg
thank you mr chairman this is for
director mcintyre is he still on the
line
he's still with us thank you director
mcintyre
for four years i've sat next to
representative mary griffin
who has my left ear most of the time
and on line two says lucky seven tickets
may be sold by dispenser devices
and then when we go down to lines 15
through 17.
does this mean that representative
griffin
seniors will still be able to get a
paper
ticket handed to them so that they can
open it close it whatever they want to
do or will
it just be by the mobile device
certainly that's to the decision of the
operator but dispensers will still be
uh available if the bingo hall still
sells that way there are
electronic machines which sell lucky
seven and then there are physical
dispensers which dispense lucky seven
tickets
very um not sophisticated
um and so the answer is yes
follow-up question mr chairman
director mcintyre on lines 11-13
uh we've been told that a deal is 3 500
tickets
now i see the the addition the
commission shall not authorize deal
sizes
over 14 000 tickets can you explain this
uh what this deal means yeah it does a
few things right so
um whenever you increase the pool size
of a game
just think of it like a pyramid you can
increase the top of the pyramid
not a good term but go ahead
um and um
the top prize can be raised also for
example
it's a consumer for us for certainly for
me
i think it's a consumer benefit only
because if the top prize in an existing
deal of 3500
4500 3500 tickets is 500
and that prize is gone then in theory
we're offering something to the public
for sale that doesn't exist anymore
as a top prize but increasing the deal
size allows more prizes of that level to
be included in the deal
so i mean certainly it's not that
significant to change if you look at a
lottery ticket for example
we have pool sizes that are five million
um some of our tickets so the 1400 14
000 is not that large a pool size for a
for a
gambling product thank you director
mcintyre
okay um i'm going to
have rick newman testify first
and rick newman is a lobbyist
from grover gaming in support of the
bill
thank you mr chairman and just to
clarify i'm representing
the um uh
yes grover gaming on this bill um
and uh i am testifying in support the
first thing i'd like to ask the
committee to focus on is
this bill deals with a different
universe of charities
than you have dealt with for instance
when you were dealing with
historic races this bill deals with
charities that sell
lucky seven tickets those are primarily
sold in new hampshire at clubs at places
like bfw's
american legions you know um
elks clubs those kinds of places there
are about
11 or 12 commercial bingo halls
in new hampshire that also sell lucky
seven tickets
but there are over 200 other locations
such as what i just mentioned where
lucky seven tickets are sold
so um this is the so it's a different
universe
of charities um
the first change in the current law
is relative to electronic dispensing
devices
the the current law requires that in
every case a ticket must be
printed this bill would allow that to be
an
option this is important to the
charities because
the rolls of paper that print those
tickets
uh cost money that money is paid for by
the charities and if it can be made
optional
it will be less cost the fact of the
matter is
people who play electronic dispensing
devices
simply don't care whether a ticket is
printed or not
they don't look at those tickets they
can see the results on the screen
on the video monitor and the
winnings kept track on the video monitor
so
they don't need the ticket to cash out
they don't look at the ticket they don't
need the ticket to know whether they
want
it is really a waste of time
um i will point out to you for instance
this past summer
there was literally a time when the
paper that is required for these
machines
was simply not available because of
covid the
manufacturer had shut down there's only
one manufacturer
that makes this double-sided
roll of paper that's required of these
machines
and so it created a problem for
charities throughout the state
because the paper was simply not
available
making it optional makes sense for the
environment makes sense for charities so
i hurt you to consider that this is a
requirement in the statute
that is simply not needed um
the other change that's made here is
that
it's actually this is actually a twofold
change you've asked a lot about the 3500
ticket uh maximum and deals how that's
uh currently provided for the current
statute
says that the lottery decides how big
ticket
the deals are so if lottery tomorrow
wanted to change the current 3 500
maximum deal size to 14 000 or 50
000 the current statute gives them that
authority
this change puts that authority back in
the hands of the legislature
by by maximizing the deal size of 14
000 that lottery can approve
if at any time there was an effort to go
beyond 14 000 it would require
further legislative action so i would i
would point out that that
i think is a benefit and
the question of why 14 000 is chosen i
will tell you is this
under the current rules set by lottery
um each charity as i said has a maximum
a deal size they can use of 3 500
but they are allowed to commingle four
deals in one
box whether that's a physical box at an
american legion
where four deals are put together in a
box or in a
mechanical dispensing device or whether
that's an electronic
game where the electronic game can
choose from
four separate deals at the same time so
a total of 14
000 tickets are currently allowed to be
co-mingled if you will um
by making the ability to have a deal
size
at 14 000 as mr mcintyre said
you increase the amount of prizes
available
which we obviously believe will attract
more players
so that's the reason for that request
and one final thing i will say is in the
senate
um the senate added if you recall last
year
um you changed the uh ticket price
maximum from 50 cents to a dollar
that stays the same in this bill you
also had a requirement
that said if you're going to sell a
dollar ticket
you have to have a 50 cent ticket
available
um for representative griffin wanted
that and
and we certainly supported it you folks
put it in the law
but inadvertently the language
meant that no longer could 25 cent
tickets be
sold so the senate added 25 cent tickets
um to that requirement as well
so if you want to sell a dollar ticket
you have to have a 25
ticket or a 50 cent ticket available as
well
for the uh offered to the public we
support that
as well we'd ask your support for this
bill thank you mr chairman
thank you mr newman and for the
questions uh representative romney
thank you mr chair uh mr newman um
bring us back in time the lucky seven
and especially for the new members
uh was something that that was the
machines
were never voted in by the house uh or
the senate
and it was it the courts refresh my
memory was the courts that
said that that these machines were okay
and was it the courts that said that
that
a piece of paper needed to come out the
bottom of the machine even though no one
looks at it
uh it was not and actually
representative rami
um it was not the court it believe it
was legislation
passed i'm thinking 2010 or 11
um that authorized the commission
of course that was the old commission to
uh allow these machines provided that
they adopted rules and in that language
in the statute
that statute required the paper ticket
to be dispensed
the court got involved because at the
time
the racing and charitable gaming
commission
decided not to promulgate rules and
a manufacturer sued the commission
and the court said the statute clearly
mandated
that the commission had to promulgate
rules that was the court involvement
the supreme court upheld that superior
court ruling
and eventually the commission did
promulgate rules
and i believe it was around 2014 or 15
that these electronic devices began to
be used in new hampshire along with the
handheld paper tickets and a follow-up
follow-up and the history is that they
wanted to simulate
what's the history of the paper why why
the paper coming out the bottom
was that to simulate the uh the hand
pull
tabs or something that people want
that's
that's correct the idea was that the
electronic device would dispense
in addition to showing on the screen it
would dispense a paper ticket
that the customer the player would hold
that ticket in their hand the way they
do
you know sitting at the bar at the
american legion or something
but what we've come to realize is that
that's simply not what happens
we literally throw away virtually
every one of those tickets in every
place that uses them at the end of the
night no customer
takes that ticket to the window no
customer looks at that ticket
it is a big pile of wasted paper uh
at the end of the day thank you all set
mr chair
okay representative ames
um yeah i can't help myself i
i need to ask this question um and it
follows
from representative abrami digging into
the
history of these provisions and uh
is the language that's repeated in this
bill it's not new language it has to be
in there because of the
change elsewhere but this is the
language that i want
to ask mr newman about the legislation
said
it says and this is already in the
statute
that any permitted lucky seven device
quote shall not be in the nature of a
slot machine
unquote it's my question to mr newman is
can you tell me what that means
uh yes i believe i can tell you what i
believe it means
uh i'm not sure i'm the definitive uh
you know resource
but my understanding of that is that it
cannot be
um slot machine in that it cannot
operate
uh on a random number generator with
unlimited
amount of prizes uh lucky seven
electronic lucky seven devices
uh as you know are uh limited to
the number of tickets available in each
deal in this case 3 500
if it went to 14 000 they'll be that
limitation so
under no circumstance could you ever win
more than 3 500
right now because and that would be if
you gave away all the money taken in
um whereas with a slot machine of course
you could win
an unlimited amount of money and the
other thing is the other significant
difference between
a slot machine and a lucky seven
dispensing device
is that a lucky seven dispensing device
uh dispenses a ticket in a predetermined
order
uh just uh you know there's already i
mean ticket number 122
is going to be a five dollar winner it
makes no difference
you know nothing can change that um you
know a ticket number 187
is going to be a loser nothing can
change that it's a matter of who
happens to buy that ticket which of
course is incredible you know very much
different than the way a slot machine
operates
i follow up thank you that's
that's helpful it's good to have that
background uh
uh put out into the hearing um
my follow-up question comes from your
pointing out that the tickets uh are in
a predetermined order in the uh
in the deal
which means that you inevitably reach a
point
where the remaining tickets to be played
have no winners among them
so that people who are playing from that
point forward
although they don't know it have no have
zero chance of winning
um is that true and is there any way to
uh abort a game when when it's reached
that point
um i believe that is true representative
just as right now if you walk into a vfw
or a legion right there might be 70
tickets left in the box of tickets
to buy and there may be no winners left
in that box and nobody
the the customer you know wouldn't
necessarily know that
um and and i would go back to what uh mr
mcintyre said
that's one of the advantages of
increasing the deal size is that you
have
uh you know more opportunities to have
winners in the deal now could there
still be a time when there are no
winners
left to play with no one knowing that
absolutely that's
that's true and i'm not sure there's a
way
to to change that um given the nature of
the way lucky seven tickets are and that
they have a predetermined amount of
winners in the
deal um so
okay we'll leave it at that unless um
director mcintyre wishes to
add to them
somebody that doesn't mean this in a
deal
how many of these
3 500 our winners
well that depends on whether it's in the
paper games i'm going to give you an
approximations
representative uh my understanding is in
your
paper ticket games the ones that a
bartender would sell you a ticket
um or that the volunteer would sell you
a ticket at the table
at a bingo game um those operate
on about a 75 payback
most of them they're not all but about
but most of them
so about 75 of the money goes back in
prizes
in the electronic games it's about 90
of the money goes back in prizes
but that doesn't answer my question
what's the number of winners
in a group of 3500
yeah i'm sorry i wouldn't be able to
know that um
it would really depend on the you know
each game is approved by the lottery
so the game has a mix of winners some 50
winners a dollar winners
um it's you know a 499 dollar winner
uh i know they try to make as many
winning potential winning tickets as
possible
because that's how you keep people
continuing to play but i couldn't give
you an exact number
charlie do you know the answer to that
i mean certainly my sense would be it's
probably one in five tickets wins but
val
are you on still valerie do you know the
answer
as rick said there's no standard because
every game is going to be different but
i think
charlie's right it's usually around one
in five
okay thank you
um representative
thank you mr chairman on i just have one
question
for rick on can you tell us what grover
gaming is is this the place that
produces the machines or what
sure grover gaming is a manufacturer of
electronic
lucky seven dispensing devices
they produce the machines
we have one other person wants to
testify
any further questions for rick newman
said none uh tyler clark
i believe you're you've been promoted
good morning chairman major can you hear
me yes
good morning chairman major and members
of the committee i will paul apologize
in advance
i have to work from home because we had
a flood at our office so i'm looking at
my dog who's asleep right now
and he's a ticking time bomb in case
there is a gust of wind so if he starts
to bark
i'm sorry but i did send the committee
a list of links last night that
hopefully uh
and most of them are videos but
hopefully they provide some clarity as
to the products that we're
discussing today uh there is a link to
what a machine in new hampshire looks
like
uh in various links that show you the
type of paper tickets that are offered
at bingo events in fraternal halls
and he is being in opposition right i am
that's correct sir
and also at the bottom of that email is
a link to all of the approved
games from the lottery commission so you
can see to answer your question
chairman major the the amount of winners
in each game because it is a list of all
the games that have been approved and
their payouts and the amount of winners
and how the game is played is in that
way
so uh diamond distributors is located in
maltenburg new hampshire
and we're one of the leading
distributors of paper lucky 7 tickets in
our state
these are the tickets sold in
conjunction with bingo games
diamond services over 80 granite state
charities with lucky seven tickets and
bingo supplies
we are on the front lines of new
hampshire's bingo industry in
an industry which has helped new
hampshire charities fundraise for
decades
and i will say while fraternals also
offer these tickets
bingos can be run in two ways they can
be run by the charity
itself for example the plasto gun club
has a function room
on the second floor so that uh club
actually runs bingo on their own with
their members
but for charities that do not have the
benefit of having their own space
they rent out a space at a commercial
hall so diamond distributors oppose the
senate bill 22
and we respectfully request that this
bill is moved itl
in prior years we've heard testimony
saying that the requirement to dispense
a paper ticket from a lucky 7 dispenser
device
is cumbersome but this ticket is what
differentiates these bright
flashy devices from an electronic gaming
machine
currently there are lucky seven
dispensing devices in facilities that to
the untrained eyes
resemble slot machines these devices
offer bright screens
moving graphics sound effects auto play
features
short intervals between each play bonus
spins
and fractional payouts rsa287e21 states
as it was pointed out by representative
ames any permitted lucky seven device
shall not be in the nature of a slot
machine
and to invoke the words of a former
colleague of mine who has since retired
and used to testify before this
committee if it walks like a duck
and quacks like a duck it's in the
nature of a duck
without the ticket being dispensed these
machines will further blur the line
between lucky 7 dispensing devices and
electronic gaming machines
there is also no guarantee this proposal
will provide cost savings or increased
revenues to charities
there is no language in senate bill 22
that states any savings from the removal
or option of the dispense tickets will
be passed down
from the manufacturers distributors and
bingo consultants
who sell operate and promote these
machines there's also concern with
increasing the maximum size of a deal
from 3 500 to 14 000 tickets
we sell our products to charities who
hold legitimate bingos
advertise these bingos and draw a crowd
at these events the most common paper
ticket deals sold
are around seventeen hundred and fifty
tickets thirty five hundred ticket deals
are less frequently purchased due to
their size
a thirty five hundred ticket deal is
even more difficult to sell during the
covet era where social distancing is
required
and event occupancy is limited it is
highly unlikely a charity operating a
real bingo
would purchase paper deals larger than 3
500 tickets
the increased size of deals would solely
benefit those who promote lucky 7
machines
and will potentially hurt charities who
run legitimate bingos
charities raise significantly more money
from paper deals than electronic deals
paper games have varying payouts but
they average a payout of 75 to 75
70 to 75 percent to the players and
leave the remaining 25 to 30 percent to
the charity
this is in comparison to the machines
which pay out roughly 90
to players and leaves 10 for charities
in fact charities that run bingo in
facilities that also offer these
machines
feel it causes them to lose revenue it
should also be noted that facilities can
have both a games of chance license
plus a bingo and lucky 7 license having
the bingo license allows games of chance
facilities to operate lucky seven
machines
considering these machines are not
limited to being solely in the room
where bingo is conducted
this then gives these facilities a
product that creates a casino vibe
lucky seven machines can be found in
hallways in rooms throughout a facility
this has led to what is called ghost
bingo ghost bingo is where there is an
intent to hold a bingo game
but it doesn't come to fruition due to a
lack of players
the intent to hold the bingo game then
allows these machines to operate
from noon to 1am this past summer
the legislature raised the maximum price
of a lucky 7 ticket from 50 cents to a
dollar
through rulemaking lucky 7 dispensing
devices had their rate of play increased
from 5 seconds to every 3 seconds
hypothetically
a player can now insert 20 dollars into
a lucky 7 dispensing device
turn on the autoplay function and the
machine will play 20 times in one minute
diamond distributors respectfully
request the committee reject further
changes to lucky 7 dispensing devices
the changes proposed in this build
further blur the line between a
dispensing device
and electronic gaming device
we're also very encouraged to see the
committee unanimously pass a bill to
study charitable gaming
since the proliferation of charitable
casinos we feel the bingo and lucky
seven industry is now often overlooked
and would welcome further study on
issues related to lucky seven
and bingo and i thank you for your
time this morning and the opportunity to
testify before the committee
thank you for your test questions
mr clark would you take questions yes i
would
uh rep senator brown thank you mr chair
uh thank you mr clark for your testimony
i i would imagine that there's one
provision in this bill that you would
support
that you didn't talk about and that
would be uh section three
the adding back of the 25 cent uh ticket
manual ticket is that a correct thought
you know we as a business don't sell too
many 25 cent tickets
um but the way i do read this
legislation is that it's actually a
mandate
for charities to buy these deals so if
somebody offers a one dollar ticket at
their bingo or you know at their
fraternal then it's stating that the
charity shall also offer
25 and 50 cent tickets so
i read that as a mandate we're pretty
neutral on that aspect of the bill but i
would just point that out to the
committee
curious thank you any further questions
yeah um sorry
i didn't have my hand up but fortunately
i was unmuted
um at least for me uh my
question is really uh whether we'll have
the written statement or maybe it's been
sent to us
last night that it was just delivered uh
it'd be good to have it
in hand mr clark did you uh
send us last night what you read this
morning
i did not send a copy last night i
figured i would save it i had a couple
edits to make this morning
i was taught when drafting something you
should always make a first draft and
sleep on it read it the next day but i'm
happy to
send it over after this hearing
thank you
mail it to the full committee
i will then i don't have to worry about
nailing that representing me
thank you this is not to on
mr clark but to on
charlie and so if it's not time for that
yet i'll wait
no that's fine go ahead
thank you on
you you told us
on that these machines
are operating now the electronic to you
in your first uh comment to on
representative schamberg on that
that the existing electronic machines do
not dispense
the law is very clearly written at this
point
that they must dispense and
that and it was written that way in
order to differentiate them
from slot machines make the play
somewhat slower
on and allow people
to on
these these machines were were
allowed in the first place simply as
dispensing machines not as electronic
gaming machines
for the convenience of the various
fraternal halls
and it seems that they have already
become
electronic gaming machines that um
[Music]
may be as uh as or more
um on
like slot machines than the ones that
were just approved for historic
racing and that are going
into a lot of fraternal organizations
that
on you have a question this this is my
question is this true
no sorry but um representative melanie
if i misspoke i apologize no the
the machines that are in place all
dispense a paper ticket
they do but they also allow i guess we
didn't specify that they
they allow you to find out that you have
won or lost
just by having on a large bell ring
on the on the screen thank you
uh representative thank you mr chair uh
this this question is for
uh charlie or valerie um
so the 3 500 ticket it doesn't exist
the 25 35 ended for the uh electronic
machines the 3 500 tickets
of what i heard i heard doesn't really
exist in statute
but uh but it is a common
number that that is used uh uh in a play
i guess
you would call it that but it was also
said that
some some establishments probably the
larger ones
will take
four boxes of these 3 500 tickets and
combine them
and load them into the machine it sounds
like so that
the 1400 already exists can you give us
a sense of
first off can you explain that a little
bit more and
to does how many how many of the
locations actually
will group different you know four boxes
together to create a larger play
valid against that yeah so the
the 3500 is not set in statute but it is
set by rule
and the rules we limit it to 3 500 we
also allow
co-mingling which means you would take
four separate deals
put them in a bowl together mix them up
and sell them at once
rather than one deal then the next deal
then the next deal
they're all sort of blended together
and sold at one time that's what
co-mingling is and that can be
up to four deals which is 14 000 tickets
right but they're actually four separate
deals just mixed together
follow-up then follow-up the debt apply
because it sounded like you were just
talking about the single tickets not the
machine
tickets but that does that also apply to
the
electronic uh lucky seven machines
yes so so the same thing would apply in
a machine
they would just um instead of having
one deal sell out at a time it would
take one ticket from one deal another
ticket from the next deal another ticket
from the next deal
and and so they have four deals playing
at once and you're never
the players not sure which deal they're
gonna get the ticket from
that helps prevent people from jackpot
hunting
where they'll stop playing a deal
because it's hit the jackpot this way by
mixing them
up it continues the play and the
interest in continuing to play
one more follow-up please one more
follow-up then we've got to move on
you know valerie so when when they load
the
these device machines is it they don't
load pieces of paper in there right
or why are they it's electronically
loaded
they could do it manually but the ones
that we currently have they've all
evolved and i believe all of them now
are electronically loaded
in from the cloud okay that's just
that's huge qualification in my mind i
just want to understand thank you
representative then we have one more
person that
showed up wants to testify i just wanted
to tell you that that
there's a fran wendell bowl that signed
up late and she's
ready in the attendees you're right i i
have an
email that was sent to me this morning
before
8 o'clock so uh lettering
okay
uh if you're on a phone it's star six to
one mute
she's on i don't know
can you hear me yes
okay took me a minute on a cell phone
how to figure out
how to do the star
are you testifying for or against
i'm testifying four okay thank you
go ahead okay uh for the record
fran wendell bow i represent powerhouse
gaming
um i'm actually in support of all of the
charitable gaming bills that are being
heard today 22
23 25 and 27 but i specifically want to
talk to
uh senate bill 22. um
i think what we need to remember is that
the charitable gaming was terribly
impacted
by kovitz and were shut down and
they're really behind the ball so to
speak and they are fundraising
for the terrible works that they do
as you've already heard uh you have
various service organizations
like the vfw and the uh legion
and all the good work they do but you
also have um
sports teams and scholarship funds
and so all of those entities are hurting
and this legislation particularly where
it talks about
the option of not having a paper ticket
that directly is paid for by the
charities they pay for the purchase of
the ticket
and the tickets that the electronic
machine use
with having to be the double um
you know the double ticket is very
expensive
and if you go and you watch people
playing
um electronic machines you'll see the
receipts coming out and just piling up
on the floor
hardly anybody actually picks up the
ticket because they
already know if they want or lost from
looking on the screen
which is great because people like me
that have bad eyesight
or have arthritis in their hands you're
not dealing
with squinting at little writing so it's
great advantage
for people to use the electronic that
are handicapped
but anyway it would save the charities
a lot of money uh and add to their
profitability
having the cost of the paper
heavily discounted by
not many people printing them the other
issue is that
the housekeeping measures of this just
cleaning up there's
nothing new happening the
co-mingling with the size of the deal
has been going on for quite
some time so there's really no impact
there but it certainly gives a lot more
flexibility
and just bear in mind i don't
know how many facilities that you've
heard from
as we all know it's difficult to get
volunteers together for these things and
so sometimes it's difficult to motivate
them
to um you know contact the committee
members and so on
so um i think that hits
the highlight of the advantages
of centerville 22. we're not expanding
we're not doing
anything that hasn't you know been
under existing law the bag and
um box issue
again is just catching up with
technology and the way these things are
printed
so um i do hope that the committee um
supports this i um thank you for
allowing me i i don't i don't know if
anybody heard but i had a 10 o'clock
emergency dental appointment
and when you walk into the dentist and
say make it fast
i was out of the chair in 15 minutes so
um
i do i hope to actively participate in
the
um subcommittee and i'm so glad that you
guys are hearing this so early
so that there is time to uh
iron out the little snags instead of
just saying oh let's throw it into
uh study because um these bills tend to
get thrown into study and
then they never get really taken up
again so i'm glad that you have the time
to accommodate
um giving it any
extra attention it needs to clarify
things
go ahead right
all right so um thank you for my
testimony
of being allowed and i look forward to
working with the committee
uh to get these bills passed thank you
did you take
questions i certainly will i'll rub some
names
yeah good good morning and uh you're
sounding amazingly vigorous in spite of
your dental
emergency
uh thank you you spoke about
uh uh the monetary difficulties
for the loss of
charitable gaming revenue um that you've
seen
and i wonder if you could help me
understand that quantify it
in terms of uh this year versus previous
years what if
what's the trend that uh was was uh
if there was a trend before this
uh past year senator before before
kovith
and and
what's happened in this most recent year
where you've indicated there's been
been difficulties representative ames
thank you for that question
i i will really need to defer to
valerie um because they were totally
shut
most of the year obviously there's been
a big
decrease so those statistics are kept
by lottery and if it's not general
access they have to go
and create a report to give it to
individuals
so perhaps valerie can give you an idea
of what
has happened this year versus
last year valerie
i have to admit i was distracted what
was the question
trying to get a handle on the uh
uncharitable gaming
revenues um the uh testimony
uh is that there's been a
significant loss uh during the covet
period
and so i'm i'm asking
for two things actually what was
happening before covet hit
to charitable gaming revenues was there
a trend
up or down and then what has happened
since then so charitable gaming
there's three different types um games
of chance has been
pretty steadily upward bingo is not
um it's continuing to
languish i guess you'd say you know it's
not getting better but it's not
necessarily
getting worse but covet did shut down
a lot of the bingo halls so there has
been left less revenue at the bingo
halls um lucky seven i'd have to look at
the numbers but i'm
my assumption is that lucky seven has
taken a slight dip as well because
there there are fewer game halls open
okay can you get numbers to us the best
numbers you have
both for that before period of time
and after broken out into those three
categories that you've just mentioned
bingo
lucky seven and uh what else
uh maybe i don't know
yeah i can do that whatever works for
you
best information available so that's
information for before the time
thank you mr chairman could we add to
that on
you you seem to be keeping records of
which halls were open
and which weren't how many on
if you've got it how many games of
chance halls
closed for how much time how many bingo
halls
and how many you said lucky seven halls
so you seem to be distinguishing
between the ones that are only machines
with no bingo
and the bingo halls thank you
we don't necessarily track that we do
keep you know when people have licenses
when the rooms have a license
and the games but we don't have that
readily available we have to
go through some of our data and compile
it
okay so this i can just take that as an
impression of that
that the lucky seven halls um
were less of them were open were
all both the bingo and the lucky seven
halls were
closing a lot of the lucky seven
are fraternal halls and a lot of them
were closed
completely
thank you any further questions
anybody else wish to testify for or
against bill 22
and i thought that was going to be an
easy bill
all right since none i'm closing the
public hearing on
senate bill 22.
let me just take a five-minute break
before we get to the next
it is now 10 47 we'll be back
at 10 52.
foreign
this
so
foreign
you
okay
well i'm waiting for the others to eat
it's how you doing
representative tucker
how are you doing oops yeah
representative major it looks like
representative malloy has now joined us
not on the phone but in person great to
see you dennis
i wrapped in malloy
all right it is 10
53. i want to open the public hearing on
senate bill 23
an act changing the requirements that a
member
of the sponsoring charitable
organization be present
during certain games of chance i have
the testifying sheet
and this
senator sherman who is the sponsor
is signed up to testify to speak
and senator french is in support but not
speaking and that's
the list of speakers let me just take a
look at the 10 days
in the attendees so
is senator sherman here
yes can you hear me yes yes we can
senator thank you mr chair and
thank you to the members of the
committee i
am here to introduce senate bill 23
for the record i am senator tom sherman
state senator for district 24
which is 11 towns on the seacoast
senate bill 23 the concept was brought
to me
by one of my constituents as you know we
have
two charitable or at least two
charitable gaming operations in
my district um
the concept or the current statute
whenever a charitable organization
is uh signed up for charitable gaming
for example
if a group had a four day run
at the brook currently they would have
to sign an affidavit they'd have to show
up
in person and sign an affidavit on
every day that the organization is
uh participating at the brook or
whichever
facility they are um
doing their their there is gaming going
on
on their behalf um sb
23 was at the request of one of these
charitable
organizations because they found that
they could
not fully participate in all the days
due to the logistics of trying to get
someone there
to actually sign the affidavit in doing
a little background on this i spoke to
the chair of the lottery commission
and the point was made that this was
actually a fairly
archaic and outdated
requirement that went back to the days
when charitable organizations organized
all of their own gaming
so that when the gaming is actually done
by another organization such as the
brook
that this is just a perfunctory
process there is really no
justification for continuing it my
original bill
just to hold on i guess a toehold of
this was to have
the charitable organization at least
show up
once during the four days uh it was
pointed out that while that's a huge
improvement over the current situation
it still might mean they have to go
across state miss
work in order to actually sign up
and senate ways and means
amended the bill to pull out any
requirement of having to show up
allowing the charitable organization to
participate fully without
having to be present during that period
of time
which i fully support um
so that's the bill that's what it does
it's pretty simple
uh and in um
and i hope you will uh support its
passage
thank you thank you would you take
questions
absolutely uh representative
thank you mr chairman
thank you senator sherman i
understand what the need is for what
you're trying to do
but there are on
four sections right immediately after
the one that you're repealing that say
that the charitable organization
is going to be on
figuring handling the money handling
who's there
all sorts of things like that and did
you look at those to try to
and how is that handled now because i do
know that
that the charitable organizations um
finesse these things somehow sometimes
at this point on if
the question of how it's handled now
might be better answered by
valerie thank you i
i agree that valerie would probably be
better at answering that
what my understanding is that the only
purpose of this person
showing up once a day
is to sign an affidavit they're not
handling any money they're not handling
anything in fact there is a prohibition
against them
even participating in the gaming so
they may cross the state to
sign in they'd have to do it every day
so this one component of that
chapter is the one that they are finding
so
finding so or onerous
if i may just on
thank you bring it out on section
roman 12 says the charitable
organization shall deposit
cash and proceeds from the game of
chance into the account required under
this chapter
and on someone is going to be paying all
expenses by check it's inferred that
it's a charitable organization
and on on
known 13 isn't applying
but on 15 says that the
on games of chance for our chips have no
monetary face value the chatter
organization may offer any number of
games per licensed event
on and 16
says the charitable organization may
offer one game per licensed event in
which each
player may spend up to 250 there are a
number of places throughout this
section of the statute that on 19
also on that
and 20 that talk about the charitable
organization's responsibilities
and i'm not sure how this fits together
with them not showing up at all
and hope that we can figure that out
thank you
thank you was that a question or
yeah yeah it's
yeah i i it my understanding in speaking
with the chairman of the commission that
this would not impact those because
these the role of this person showing up
is
simply to sign the affidavit they don't
have
any other role
so the rest of it it might be a good
topic for the commission
that was discussed with the last two
bills
looking at charitable gaming whether
these are still pertinent
but the role of the person showing up to
sign the affidavit is
solely to sign the affidavit in my
understanding
and that is what is onerous
for the organizations many of whom
have no permanent staff
have no officers to go over except
people who are also working so they have
to take time off from work they have to
travel
none of which is reimbursed so
that was the goal um but i agree with
you
that you know there are some concerns
potentially later on in the statute but
i don't believe that this impacts them
valerie do you have anything to add to
that
um yes so i just wanted to clarify that
he is correct the affidavit is is
from years ago when the charities did
run their own
games and this was sort of a as they
started to switch to game operator
employers who are much
more savvy at how to run games properly
they continued the charity's
participation through the affidavit but
it really doesn't provide
any um assurances about um
it has nothing to do with the gaming
integrity
it's really just they go in they sign a
piece of paper
they don't accept any money they aren't
doing anything other than saying
yep we're here and yes this game
night is our night um so we have no
objections to having that removed and
it because it really doesn't serve any
purpose as far as
our needs to ensure the integrity of the
games
as far as paying checks and depositing
money
we do require um because the statute
does
say that all licensees have to have a
criminal background check
so we do require whoever is accepting
that money on behalf of the charity it's
usually the chairman
or the treasurer does have to have a
criminal background check they would
pick up the money
and deposit it into the charities bank
account
thank you any further questions
i don't see any further questions there
is a handful
whoops a representative
thank you this is a follow-up to valerie
when it
so the member f
the treasurer of the association of the
organization has to
travel to this place to pick up
the money and count it and take it to
their bank account not necessarily
um it's typically i'm not there's no
requirement that they physically go to
the location but they're the ones who
are
accepting and depositing the money it
has to be the chairman or the
or the treasurer or designee but they
they may do it other ways we don't
require that they go in person to pick
up the check
all right representative elliot
you're muted bob
okay i just wanted to say hi to tom
sherman i don't have a question
i hope you're well tom keep up thank you
representative great to see you as well
as all the other friends on this
uh zoom it's great to see everybody
any further questions of senator
chairman uh
rick newman has his hand up in the
attendees
okay a lot of men but representative
elmi
you have a further yeah this is
essentially a question to
senator sherman if he would mind if we
try to clean up this language
because on you may call it archaic but
it was put in by representative wyler
when he got
charitable gaming established about a
decade ago
on and um on a lot of it does put
responsibilities on the charitable
organization which the charitable
organization
i don't think should be be responsible
for
because they are not involved in
this operation except to receive money
if i can answer that i i would be more
than
happy to have the bill as is
as often how happens when our bills come
to the house
have it improved and uh the only
thing i would ask is that uh and i
didn't mean any offense
by calling it archaic maybe vestigial is
better
um but the uh the only thing i would ask
is that
we keep intact the original intent which
is
this this uh this bill has been
enjoys the support of both the
charitable organizations as well as the
charitable gaming operators
because it removes something that as
valerie said
really serves no purpose and um
but any other uh changes that you want
to make that would be supported by the
commission and the committee are are
i'm i would more than welcome them
valerie you have your hands up
yes i just wanted to give some
assurances to representative almi
regarding some of the other requirements
in the statute that are on the
charitable organization
um charitable organizations technically
can run their own
games of chance events most of them
don't because it's very complicated and
onerous
when they hire a game operator employer
to run those games on their behalf
those requirements shift to the game
operator employer who is
doing the operation on behalf of the
charity
all right all right uh
would you let me see
yes talking permission
thank you mr chairman um i will uh
briefly try to sign up for this and i
apologize i guess i
i didn't do it correctly but i briefly
voted against the bills uh speaking in
favor of the bill
behalf of the new hampshire charitable
gaming operators association
um and just uh two quick points i want
to make
many of our rooms have run into the
situation where
a charity you know wanted to participate
in charitable gaming but because they
were located
or their members were located so far
from the room
it became impossible to let them
uh operate because you you couldn't get
somebody who could drive
in some cases 30 40 miles you know every
single day round trip
to come in and i do want to reiterate
what valerie said
what we're talking about here is a
person
who uh drives to belmont
you know appears at the front desk is
handed a piece of paper
signs it it says i'm here and then
literally walks out the door
they don't have any further involvement
the statute doesn't require
any further involvement and so it really
has it really is a requirement that's
run its course
and does impede certain charities from
being able to participate
um on the issue that uh a good point
that representative almi raised about
the statute
referring to the responsibilities of the
charity again i just would reiterate
the statute does say that when a charity
hires a game operator employer
those responsibilities now become the
responsibility
of the game operator employer so the
game operator employer
does all of those things on behalf of
the charity
and deposits the money in a separate
account each day etc um
and but one
one final thing i will tell you that
when the bill was of this law was
originally passed
the requirement was a charity had to be
present all day long
and that was changed to the just show up
and sign a paper
and uh frankly i think you know even
that's run its course so
we would support this change and ask you
support the bill
any questions of rick newman
i see no hands up is there anybody else
in the attendees
janine anybody else want to ask
no questions then i'm going to close the
public hearing
on senate bill 23.
now we're gonna make a little change to
senate bill
25 i got a call from
senator morse he's the sponsor and the
only sponsor on this
senate bill 25 and he asked if i would
introduce it since he's
tied up with the governor this morning
so i'm going to have
uh representative
romney take over his chairman
okay thank you mr chair um i'm going to
open the
hearing on house bill 25 relative to
charitable gaming licenses
and i think representative major
is going to introduce the bill
thank you mr chairman my name is
representative norm major
representing rockingham 14 towns of
atkinson and plasto
i'm here at the request of senator morse
and which
let me explain this is a straightforward
bill
requested by a constituent of his to
streamline
the administration of terrible naming
under current law charities may operate
games of chance
10 times per year senate bill
25 doesn't change this
currently these 10 days are reset on the
anniversary when the license was
issued this date is different for every
charity
so the groups running the games on their
behalf must track the anniversary dates
for every single
charity which is very
administrative nightmare senate bill 25
resets the clock on december 31st for
everyone
each licensed charity gets 10 days
during the calendar year
the same as before this is a simple
change that will make it easier to
administer
charitable gaming in new hampshire then
the senator asked
for your support thank you
any uh any questions for representative
major
well okay i see none oh yes a
representative army
simply on this bill is in is within
uh senate bill 27 senator guida's bill
on how do we handle that
well if senator guida's bill
gets tied up in a
in work sessions and is retained
and this goes forward
this is simple this doesn't have the
baggage
as the other bill does
follow up did i have a follow-up then
follow up
on it do you have an explanation from
him as to why they picked one
two years oh no this
one doesn't affect the one year versus
two-year issue i beg your partner
this is a simple bill it doesn't change
the number of games
it doesn't change the licensing but
it says the licensing terminates the
31st of december
and you have to renew it every year and
when you do you're going to get your 10
days
where it is now the 10 days that's
the date that you get your license and
when you keep have to keep track of
all the various charities uh it's
much more difficult than it is if
everybody has to start
at january one
okay any other any other questions for
representative major
i don't see anything is here so they may
be able to
uh i'm going to ask valerie in a second
i just want to um
mr uh uh representative major so
jenny uh as of eight o'clock this
morning that there was no one
else on the list to speak do you see any
anybody out there that wants to speak
rick newman has his hand up
okay let me ask uh uh can we can we let
him in
and i want to ask uh valerie king a
question
can valerie can you just uh embellish
why uh having all these different dates
currently
is a problem and why going to the one
date would help you out
um prior to a few years ago it was the
single date
it was the the licenses are good for a
calendar year
it that got changed a few years ago
because of
one constituent but it really wreaked
havoc with the rest
of us um so having it converted back to
the old way does make it a lot easier
for the rooms to
um follow their their charities license
dates
and it it equally makes our lives a
little easier here in
the lottery okay thank you
any anybody have any questions for uh
for valerie
king yeah i do i do um representatives
yes
is this is indirectly related but uh
we're talking about the number of days
here
um we're actually just changing the time
of the license but the license is
um allows the charity to operate
um games of chance for 10 days
which 10 days need not be consecutive
the question arises because we've got
another bill that we've
sent to the floor involving historic
horse racing
uh gaming and uh
specifying that for every day
of operation of those games
there must be two charitable gaming
charitable organizations uh
participating
and
does does is is there any potential for
confusion between those
two different rules that may apply to
the same
gaming place
um no there won't be any issues with
regard to having two charities play at
once
this actually makes it a little easier
because you can keep the same two
charities at the same time they'll all
be licensed the same
time period they can coordinate it a
little easier i think
um the historic horse racing requirement
won't have any impact
okay thank you
question uh any other questions of uh
valor king
okay seeing none uh uh rick newman
uh you'd like to testify go ahead thank
you mr chairman
rick newman speaking in favor of the
bill
representing the new hampshire
charitable gaming operators association
um just very briefly i will tell you
that when the change took place
um all of our rooms saw a lot of
logistical problems it just is a
difficult
thing to keep track of whose license
expires
when um and as
ms king said it it was a change that was
asked for by one organization because
they
had misunderstood when their license
expired
um it was done as an amendment to a
senate bill
a few years ago nobody saw it and
when we realized what happened we
realized then it was
going to be a problem and it has turned
out to be a problem
this is a good simple change that will
help not only the lottery but the game
operators as well
thank you mr chairman okay thank you
mr newman any questions for mr newman
i don't see any hands uh jenny are there
any
other folks out there that want to
testify you see any other hands
no no we're all set okay
so any other questions of the members
okay seeing none i think we'll are going
to
close the hearing on house bill 25
uh represent a major you back in the
chair seat
thank you pat see how quick i can do it
just joking okay
i'm going to open the public hearing on
senate bill 48
relative to the formula used to
determine
current use tax rates and
the testifying sheet
shows there's three people on a speak
the crime sponsors bob geider
he's here the next is jason stock
a lobbyist in support and then
robert johnson a lobbyist new hampshire
farm bureau
also
so uh senator geiter
go ahead and introduce you bill
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee uh for the record bob guida
state senator district two uh prime
sponsor senate bill 48
uh this bill uh was
the topic of this bill was pointed out
to me by a person who is very active in
issues of property taxation and so forth
uh
it is it is a a part of our legislation
that is i find repugnant
as you know on ways and means every
formula for every tax
that is levied on our citizens and
businesses is a matter of public record
with one exception and that is the
formula that's utilized to determine
uh the um
[Music]
current use property taxation uh this
was the result inadvertently of the
the blanket confidentiality that is
issued to anything that has to do with
the department of revenue administration
under which the
current use board resides
and so having spoken with
the commission of revenue and she and
the department are totally with this
bill
uh and in the interest of maintaining
fuel transparency in government one of
the things that we all find very very
um compelling this bill is brought in
just to remove the components of the
formula and the formula
itself from the confidentiality blanket
that's issued to
all dra
regulations and so all it does is it
adds
under d under rsa21j colon 14 roman 4
it inserts one additional thing that is
exempted from the confidentiality that's
the formula used by the department
to assist the current youth board in a
determination of current use tax rates
and all variables within that formula
including definition of those variables
if any
there are private properties that are
utilized in determination
of the level of taxation that
information will remain totally
confidential
but the formula itself uh cries out to
be
as all other taxation formulas are
available to the public without any uh
infringement thank you mr chairman
thank you senator any questions for the
senator
uh representative romney thank you
senator goddard
this is funny when i first read this
bill yesterday
my reaction was where's the formula
and i kept on searching for the formula
and i couldn't and the bill is
to do what you just said so i i think i
think this is a good idea
uh to uh let everybody be able to see
the formula more of a comment than
anything else thank you
uh representing
thank you mr chairman senator
on i believe
that this formula is also invisible
to those of us who have land which is
not in current use but which is under
deed restriction
by the planning boards um and
on from developments
that were create sub uh created
subdivisions
and um i wonder would this also
it would i believe apply to them as far
as i know this concerns entirely
timberland which is in current use
and on every now and then is
harvested and in my case
we harvested my associations timberland
on over a decade two decades ago now
and had to pay the timber tax but had no
idea how much
we were going to have to pay when we
started
and when we hired somebody to do it so
that you can't
tell whether you're going to make a
profit or a loss we were quite surprised
to discover we were making a profit
30 of which went to the town so is that
what this is about
uh and would it also would
opening up this formula for
current use also apply to the formula it
would be the same formula wouldn't it
for subdivisions that had d restrictions
yeah i think the current the intent of
the legislation
is to make the formula transparent to to
any who would use it or or
just be interested in looking at it uh
again it's repugnant i think to our
ethics
uh that a taxation formula is hidden
and it's the only one of its kind in the
state everything else we can go to dra's
website and find out formulas and so on
and so forth parameters metrics
but here we have taxation without if you
will
exposure to the formula that develops it
i guess yes in a short way yes
any further questions for senator geider
saying none we have
sign up in support of the bill is a
jason stock who is a lobbyist from the
new hampshire
timberlane owners association uh mr
stock
good morning can you can you hear me yes
all right wonderful well well thank you
for the opportunity to testify in
support of
senate bill 48 as you had mentioned i am
the
director of the new hampshire timberland
owners association our members
of about 1300 members across the state
who
own or manage over a million acres of
timberland
and much of that is enrolled in current
use
we're very active in the current use
rate setting process and we're act
actually
active when the formula that is used to
determine
or calculate the assessment rate
when that was re when that was developed
a number of years ago and
when senator gaida brought this bill
forward i was
frankly i was surprised that that that
formula was not
public knowledge and we feel it should
be um
there's nothing to hide there it is a it
is a pretty straightforward
cash flow net present value cash flow
analysis
done looking at timberland and looking
at timberland
from as if it were an investment
looking at it to determine all right
what are the costs
what are the and what are the revenues
that can be expected from that
timberland
and it calculates and includes things
such as growth
timber growth rates looks at different
tree species
so it is a it is a a pretty
standard model and we feel it should be
it should be publicly available for
folks to look at
i also want to stress a point that
senator gaida had mentioned is
when the model was being developed there
were
there was a question about what are
management costs what management cost
should be included in the model
for instance maintaining boundary lines
doing timber inventories things of that
nature
and so the department of revenue reached
out to us
and other timberland owners across the
state and said
can you provide us some examples of what
your cost
on a per acre basis would be
for those types of activities and so
they get they did a sampling of
timberland owners across the state
gathered that information on an
anonymous basis
and then were able to use that to calcu
to plug into this vap into this model to
calculate those carrying
carrying costs on this land and
you know that was done with an
expectation of confidentiality
and again this we believe this bill does
not
does not um go against that
that promise and we are supporting it
um again i wanted to speak to
representative almi's questions
timber tax is is separate
it is part it is included in the model
but timber tax is looked and based
on the value of that stumpage in other
words
that tree that's growing on in the
ground
on your property your timber tax is
assessed
on that value whereas current
so current use assesses the land
beneath that tree so current use
determines what is the productive
capability
of this acre of land you know how much
timber can that acre of land grow what
is the cost to maintain that acre of
land
when you and then that's how it's
assessed annually as a
a property tax when you cut that temp
when that timber is on your property
growing as stumpage
it is considered real property at the
time of severance
it used to be called the severance tax
at the time of severance
that real property then becomes personal
property
and it's at that point that the timber
tax is assessed
and it's assessed based on the stumpage
value
this value of that tree standing and so
the model does take that into
consideration
taxes paid when they calculate what are
your carrying costs
etc as for lands with conservation
easements
um many cut there is a a provision
in in state law another i think it's rsa
79b that allows conservation easement
land
um to be assessed based again on
current use rates it essentially defers
to rsa 798
which is your current use rate but
in almost all instances conservation
easement land
is assessed using the current use
model rsa which is rsa 79a
and so uh just to affirm
that yes senator guy is correct by
making this model for current use
assessment
publicly available by de facto
it's also publicly available for those
lands under conservation easements that
are assessed
under this mechanism so i hope i
answered those questions and
i'd be happy to field any other
questions and we
hope you support senate bill 48
thank you well thank you for your
testimony
um representative ellen
thank you i'd just like to thank
mr stock for clarifying something that i
hadn't quite understood
and to correct something i said the
timber tax
is 10 on i belong to a homeowners
association
and we get taxed by a 60-year-old
federal bill
on at 30 percent of that
that's the profit gotcha
that's just a statement right
okay um further questions
saying none then i'm going to have
well thank you uh mr stark the next one
to testify is robert johnson
a lobbyist from the new hampshire farm
bureau federation
and support
um i'm assuming can you hear me chairman
major
yes is that 877
robert johnson
is the tell hello is it tim hammy
yes is the telephone number 877 robert
johnson
yeah okay
then go ahead with your testimony
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee for the record
my name is rob johnson i represent the
new hampshire farm bureau
as the federation's policy director
of farm bureau consists of 10 county
farm bureau organizations which which
consist
of nearly uh 2 000 family
farm members as well as a thousand other
members
and we are in in strong support of
senate bill 48
is no program
more important to maintaining our work
and finding force wins in
the state of new hampshire than the
current use assessment program
and we want the public and decision
makers to have the information they need
and to have a good understanding of the
program and and so that there's full
transparency
you know we've like like mr stock
alluded to
we are kind of surprised that the
formula is not public
we have both attended numerous meetings
and hearings where the formula has been
made available on and overhead in front
of us and with handouts
and and i'll leave my testimony at that
thank you
thank you for your testimony mr johnson
are you the same johnson that was uh
sergeant of arms at one time i am
okay i thought it was one in the fame
questions for mr johnson
saying no questions uh thank you for
your testimony
thank you anybody else wish to testify
for
or against uh senate bill 48
saying none i'm going to close the
public hearing on senate bill 48.
patrick has his hand up
i i took it down norm you you closed the
hearing so i just wanted to know if
miss lear wanted to testify or not
but you already know the hearing that's
a good point
uh um unclose it or officially unclose
the hearing
um would you let commissioner
carolyn learn
yeah i've just let her in
commissioner lear do you have any
comments on senate bill 48
commissioner lears from the dra good
morning carolyn lear assistant
commissioner at the new hampshire
department of revenue
um i don't have anything really to add
we don't take
a position on the bill but i can confirm
that senator guy to work closely with us
to come up
with this language and we have no issue
with providing this exemption well thank
you for your testimony
any questions of commissioner
assistant commissioner leer none
now i will officially close the public
hearing on senate bill 48
thank you
i'm opening the public hearing on senate
bill 103-fn
relative to nexus provisions for certain
disaster related or emergency related
work performed
in the state and this was
presented by senator bradley
is senator bradley here yes he is
senator bradley the floor is yours
senator bradley is muted
oh i think i'm okay now can you hear me
sir
good morning uh mr chairman how are you
and members of the committee
all right so
um thank you very much it's a pleasure
to be here as the sponsor
of senate bill 103. um
this bill deals with nexus provisions
for
disaster related work that's performed
in new hampshire it was
brought to me by telecommunications
companies
and utilities because often
they must bring into new hampshire
resources
and personnel from other states to try
to get
our systems back online and snowstorms
floods hurricanes that kind of situation
when these personnel
in particular are here and they operate
in new hampshire temporarily to help our
state recovery
they should not be burdened and the
employees should not be burdened
with regulations that prevent them from
actually working
in new hampshire as easily as possible
during an emergency and those things are
taxes
licensing registrations
that type of thing so what this bill
would do mr chairman is streamline or
remove the type of obstacles
that can happen in a declared state of
emergency
when personnel or property come into new
hampshire that ordinarily would not be
here
it streams streamlines licensing
permitting unemployment provisions
business profits tax and business
enterprise tax
other states like connecticut maine and
vermont
have reciprocity agreements that exempt
new hampshire employees from this type
of thing when our
employees go to those states to help
them recover
from an emergency this would provide
that kind of benefit
to make sure that we're able to get
people
and equipment into our state during
emergencies
i would just add finally mr chairman
that any out of state folks that come in
here
would fully pay any gasoline taxes or
the rooms and meals tax
or any specific transactions so
the senate passed this bill i believe it
was on the consent calendar and we
commend it to you
thank you mr chairman thank you for your
testimony
senator would you take questions uh sure
although i think there probably will be
other
um people more knowledgeable than i but
i'll do my best to answer questions
okay uh rep representative i actually
represented sorry
okay uh thank you um
and this may be a question for for those
others that you just referred to
but um my sense looking at it looks like
a very good deal
let me start there and um bills again
um but my question to you is whether
uh this is true it also looks like a
bill that uh
may uh be a template for bills that are
being offered
around the country and um
my question to you is that the case and
do you know whether
other states are also enacting bills
like this
yeah thank you very much uh
representative my understanding is that
it is based off of you know some of the
agreements that i cited um with in
connecticut maine of vermont
but again some of the utility
representatives and let's remember that
they have
businesses in or the
the utilities that serve new hampshire
also serve other states
so um there would be some
um continuity if you will and
reciprocities
but ask i think it'd be best to ask them
that specific question
thank you any question questions for
senator bradford sen none
thank you senator bradley yeah thank you
representative major good to see you
see you here uh the next is
owen smith who's a member of the public
representing a t bill
mr smith good morning can you
hear me we can hear you yes good morning
uh mr chair thank you members of the
committee for
this opportunity um uh att
appreciates uh the opportunity to
express support for this
uh mike owen smith i'm the state
president
for atp here in new hampshire
i'd also like to thank senator bradley
for sponsoring this bill and
understanding the role that private
organizations like atp
play in disaster response
att provides communication services
across the country we have
for 140 years we have a little bit of
history of responding to
emergency situations and
the fact that so much critical
infrastructure
is owned by private companies it's
important to have an effective
emergency planning and response um and
it should
really promote a partnership between
the private sector and the government
and i think that that's certainly what
this bill is all about
um after events on 9 11
the 911 commission created the first net
authority
and in 2017 at t was awarded the
first net contract by the federal
government for
the next 25 years of which we're three
years into what i believe
first is a public safety nationwide
communications platform
we've been very busy here in new
hampshire and elsewhere across the
country over the last three years
building the first net network along
with att's commercial network
to a certain extent it's it's one in the
same but
first responders here in new hampshire
uh rely on firstnet
again which is built and maintained by
uh
atnt so um
last year's hurricane season is a great
example of why we need something like
this
and why we're asking for it with other
members of the industry it was
the most active and fifth costliest
hurricane season on record
uh 12 hurricanes made landfall onto the
u.s
fema reported 16 major disasters last
year
um there were actually five major
disaster declarations
over the past three years here in new
hampshire
and so eliminating barriers that hinder
the response is really key to effective
um
recovery and i think that the covet 19
pandemic
underscores the importance of reliable
communication networks as
many of us continue to see what we're
doing today working from home
uh learning from home
the so our network employees came to us
a number of years ago um and
senator brown is correct other states
are doing this 32
states have done this across the country
um most recently connecticut at the end
of last year their session
uh maine and vermont
also had this in place and our employees
basically came to us and others
in the industry um with this issue of
roadblocks and legal requirements
that are otherwise aimed at normal
business conditions which
respond to a disaster is not so
we basically uh got together went to um
csl they put uh
we work with them putting a model
together that um
the basis of sb 103 is uh
built on uh very similar to 32 other
states
and uh so that's that's really where we
are today and i
i just like to sort of finish up and uh
big comment um the sra
basically says in the fiscal note that
uh the bill would result in an
indeterminable uh increase in revenue
um and i'm not an expert um and i don't
want to
argue that but i'll just say that i
believe that the impact on revenue
is is de minimis this is not about a
cost reduction for at t
or or these other companies this is
really about getting um
the network back up and running after a
disaster um this is about creating
certainty and
um you know a swift response to network
outages
uh you might even would argue maybe
that um if you have networked this down
and no one able to use it that you're
not generating
um tax revenue for the state of new
hampshire while it's down
so this potentially could have an impact
a positive impact
on this so anyway
sb 103 does not impact atp's operation
or employees or any
business entity dealing with a crisis in
the state
who normally operate in new hampshire as
atp does
we are liable for the taxes the
registration the licensing or any other
regular
course of business requirement that will
continue
under this bill so this again
is about bringing resources to new
hampshire during specifically a declared
state of emergency by the governor of
the president
our property and personnel from other
states which
previously um has had no connection to
new hampshire that's really what this is
all about so
um i'll stop there and answer any
questions if people have them
thank you for your testimony mr smith
questions
uh representative romney
uh thank you mr chair thank you mr uh
smith
for your testimony now 18t is a large
company
i'm sure you have a footprint in most
states in
in the union and other places
so how does this impact uh apportionment
of taxes between states for your
efforts so i'm trying to understand how
this bill
plays out i mean if there's an emergency
on the coast because the hurricane came
through
and you sent a team from vermont to new
hampshire because it didn't really
impact vermont but it
impacted new hampshire what does this
bill
do to uh your
how your profits uh taxes on your
profits
in a portion between the states is there
an impact
so it so i think you should probably be
talking about the business profits tax
and business
tax if if it really wouldn't
impact us certainly from a financial
standpoint
um again we're here this year we're
doing business with other states
so if it wouldn't really that it
wouldn't really impact that
what this really addresses is um some
affiliates that don't do business
in this state and um also
uh third parties that that we get
come in to help us whether it's um
delivering fuel to generators um which
att is not in that business so we rely
on third parties to do that um
and it's as much about um here's
here's another example where you might
have an electrician that needs to come
in and do some work
well if you're not if you're based in
new hampshire
and are a master electrician you'd be
licensed well if you bring
a licensed election from
connecticut he's probably not going to
have a license in new hampshire
basically this bill is saying that's
okay if he's licensed
under connecticut law and that's where
he's coming from he doesn't need to have
a a license in new hampshire um
during you know 10 days prior to
the disaster relief declared emergency
in 60 days following that's all this
bill's saying
so it might licensing
unemployment provisions we have to ask
volunteer employees to come in and help
out
and some of the first things that they
look at is well
do i have to file taxes in new hampshire
now am i going to get another tax return
you know what about fico what what about
you know how does this impact me
and we just want all of that to go away
um and that's really what this is all
about
thank you you're welcome
representative jenny thank you mr
chairman
and thank you mr smith for taking my
question um i guess i just have a
question
on um on the liabilities side of this if
businesses are are are coming in that
the state of new hampshire doesn't know
who they are
is for example in the case of att if
you're bringing in
contractors who aren't licensed in the
state the state doesn't know anything
about them
where does liability fall if there's
some issue with the contractor
so in order to be a contractor of a t
they have to have the attic
liability um and um
i i don't i don't know
if i can answer that question it just
it doesn't it really doesn't change
anything
um there is a uh
reporting requirement um if requested by
the secretary of state
um that is in this bill
that would um if requested upon by the
secretary of state
they would have to supply their name
state of domicile
uh principal business address telephone
number all of that information
and proof that they actually do have a
license
say in the state of connecticut to be an
electrician so
that's that's in place
i hope that answers questions follow up
mr chairman
follow up so i i did see that in the
bill
and uh that's good the only thing is
that requires
uh the state to request it if the state
isn't aware
and hasn't requested it um then uh
you know i guess that that's just where
my i'm not sure it's a problem i'm just
trying to
you know understand whether there is a
problem there with
liability uh in a case where the state
doesn't know
who it is i mean in the case of att
you're saying that you
any contractor you're bringing on you've
already made sure they have their own
liability insurance um
so i guess is there i guess the question
is greater question is
att may be acting responsibly um we
don't know if other
contractors are like and again maybe
this isn't even a problem i just want to
raise it as a is it a potential issue is
my question
yeah um and and i may not have the
answer to that specifically
i do have an example of where we had a
contractor in
doing some work on a uh on a site um
this wasn't during an emergency but
they were a vendor and they may have
even been an in-state
vendor but they actually did some damage
to some public safety equipment on
on the uh on the tower we took full
responsibility of it it was work that
was being done
for us we took full responsibility for
it so
again i'm not sure that answers your
question um but there are 32 other
states that have
very very similar bills to this
and i have not heard of that as being an
issue thank you
thank you representative ames
followed by representing yearly
thank you um i think you may have just
answered my question with your reference
to the 32 other states but
my question follows up on my earlier
question to senator bradley and that is
uh can you speak to the degree to which
other states
um have or are in the process of acting
on similar legislation of uh
so enacted the provisions that are in
this bill
yeah so um 30 students 32 states already
have
very similar bills um i believe that uh
while connecticut
just um passed almost the identical bill
uh i think in october november of last
year right at the very end of their
session
and uh uh tennessee was also
um the state that just passed this
i want to say maybe even january of this
year but very recently
and then i believe this bill
is also in massachusetts
i was involved with the main one maine
was actually the first state back in
2014 or 15
to put this into place um
and vermont followed shortly after that
okay good that's helpful as a follow-up
follow-up
question yeah
[Music]
so following up on representative
genigion's
question and perhaps you don't know but
do you know whether in any of those
states there's
been a a problem with liability with
contractors coming in under this
umbrella
who may not be properly insured
or maybe irresponsible
so um again i am not aware of that
um i would say
that this this model language has been
around and probably been tweaked over
the years
if this was was an issue in some state
or multiple states my assumption is that
they would have
uh changed the language to address that
so i i really don't think that it's an
issue
and again in a t's point and i think
we're talking about
uh lots of big multinational companies
here in utilities um
i i think we would step up and um
take full responsibility but again i
don't think that's been an issue
obviously thank you that's a good answer
thank you
representative
thank you mr chair i appreciate that you
you made a comment that just kind of
tweaked my
curiosity mr smith uh you said you
certainly you know in a disastrous
situation you may call in somebody from
outside
of new hampshire to refuel your
generators
well that doesn't seem to be very cost
effective number one
you're hauling bulk fuel across state
lines
and the other thing is how would this
bill
not operate to deny
business opportunities to new hampshire
entities
that may not be directly affiliated with
you as a as a subscribed
contractor already but are ready willing
and able
to do uh um tower work for you
well so the the fuel situation
i'm not an expert on on how we respond
to disasters um i do know that we have
um third parties whether they're in
state or out of state
um that that drive around a few
steel trucks and and uh fill up our
generators where needed
there's lots of different types of um
uh contractors that we would um either
use within state and
you know we we pay um you know seven
million
in local estate taxes and um i don't
have the figure in front of me but
um spend millions of dollars on local
in-state
um partners uh to do business goods and
services
so uh you're right it would make much
better business sense to bring
um to to work local which we do you know
of the time i believe um and and we've
got 150 employees
155 here in the state that
work here in the state um exclusively
for the most part
unless they need to go to another state
for an emergency so
um in most cases we would do that but
there are
maybe some specialties or you know we
we've got assets that we bring in that
we station
we've got assets here in the state um as
well um these
satellite um cults or cows that we can
put up a temporary
sell site we've got those to state but
we may need more than we have in state
so we've got to get somebody from
um again whether it's an att employee in
connecticut or new jersey
to drive these things up or maybe a
third party
to drive these things up we use a lot of
subcontractors
um both in and out of state so i hope
hopefully that answered your question
are you all safe i've seen you thank you
mr chair
okay um representative spellsbury
thank you mr chairman i have two
questions i'll take them one at a time
if i may
uh going back to representative
jeanine's
question on the notification clause but
setting aside the consideration of
liability just the mechanics of notice
seems to have it backwards how's the
secretary of state going to divine the
presence
of emergency workers um
so would it would you have any objection
if in the second line of that provision
we simply deleted the three words upon
request by
and made notice mandatory to be
initiated by
the uh business or contractor
i'm sorry what what's the question
specifically
if we take the words upon request by
from the notice of the secretary of
state
then we eliminate the need for the
secretary of state
to divine your presence and request a
notice
you just simply say you have your pride
and notice any objections
um i mean i i understand
why you would want to do that but but
this this bill
is all about streamlining and and again
i don't believe that the liability issue
is
is truly an issue or it would be
specifically addressed in
this bill and in 30 my question has
nothing to do with reliability it's just
about notice
okay um you know taking that out would
would be a
uh put a process in place that's not in
place today
that would um uh make us
take that step and that that's what
we're trying to avoid here
is streamlining it and making it very
hopefully identical in all 50 states so
if we've got a
storm that came up and we we were in
multiple states and moving people from
each state we wouldn't have to
worry about in new hampshire we've got
to notify the
the secretary of state um so really what
we're trying to do is streamline
the operations the the um the process
involved in getting employees and assets
into the state
okay your second question
yes thank you uh so out of state
business
in chapter
5 319 d5
is uh defined not to have a presence in
the state now in the case of 18t do you
have
a distinct corporate affiliate operating
in each state
and so effectively when you bring in
property or employees they're coming
from
a different corporate entity is that
basically
correct thank you
yeah representative
thank you mr chairman on mr smith
on that same one on the bottom of
page 1 roman
8 registered business
is defined on a place
in in this that specifies
that what we're talking about is
businesses
that are specifically um
on telecommunications and utilities
or could it also apply to
a um dunking
dunking donuts franchises
from outside or somebody like that that
was going to bring in emergency
food supplies on and groups that
that would be a lot less organized the
way you want to be organized and should
be organized
i i believe this bill is
focused at repairing
and restoring physical equipment
and buildings and infrastructure
i don't believe it would pertain to
dunkin donuts bringing in
food for att workers or anybody else
so no i don't so i think it's pretty
specific on
uh what kind of a business this would
and the work that they're doing
would uh qualify under this
and is that in the language somewhere
sorry follow-up
yes it's uh let's see
status of out-of-state business uh let's
see
under section 10 39
d2 status of out-of-state business
employees during
disaster period notwithstanding
reform disaster related in emergency
related work
during a disaster response period
under d3
any any out of state business that is
present in the state
or conducts operations in the state to
perform disaster related or emergency
related
work during a disaster response period
so i think it's
mentioned in a few different places in
the bill
it looks like day two
the trajectory paragraph may
may specify that
but yeah critical infrastructure exactly
personal property including but not
limited to buildings condo
lines fiber optic cable poles pipes
structures
own owned or used by public utility or
rural cooperative
or provider communication services which
is what a t would be
i think so but i couldn't find the place
he was reading from i was reading from
line six to ten
on page yeah that that's i was just
reading from that too
um the critical infrastructure
it's actually line um yes
on page uh page one
excuse me yeah uh it's line seven eight
nine and ten
that's a definition and then critical
infrastructure isn't
used in page 2
uh line 6 to 10.
yeah mr chair perhaps i could help
yes i think
you have to put things together here i
think it's pretty well done
the the definition of critical
infrastructure we were just talking
about
then that keys into the next definition
which is disaster related or emergency
related work
which is repairing renovating and so
forth
to critical infrastructure so it's
picking up the critical infrastructure
there
and then if you go to the sort of the
focus of the bill which is the status of
out-of-state businesses on the page two
the provision is that no out-of-state
business or out-of-state
employee who is present in the state or
conducts operations in the state to
perform disaster related or emergency
related work that's the definition we
were just
looking at um thank you
you got it okay i'll leave it there
we have one other person signed up
in support of the bill but not
testifying
and that's more a western lobbyist from
new england cable and telecommunications
association
and i think we all got a
letter from a gerard keegan
from cedar ragan which is another
wireless communication industry in
support of this bill
the only thing i want is
carolyn lear from the dra is here do you
have anything
to any comments on this bill
thank you representative carolyn lear
assistant commissioner at the new
hampshire department of revenue
you have the bill with our fiscal impact
statement
at the back of the bill and i think
that's relatively
self-explanatory i think the proposed
legislation could result in businesses
not having nexus with new hampshire for
disaster recovery work
here in the state um
who would no longer have nexus if this
bill were passed and that is why we
have indicated that there would be a um
indeterminable reduction
in revenue um i'm happy to answer any
questions that the committee has
about that
representative thank you mr chairman
helen on none of the
if a business had some kind of nexus
now on but on
was based outside of new hampshire and
provided emergency services
under this would they be at all
could you still continue to tax them for
the nexus they had
otherwise i interpret the answer to
i interpret the bill um as saying that
yes
it's more of a but four situation where
but
for the disaster the business would not
have nexus
then we would not capture them but if
they would all
if they would have nexus otherwise i
don't think this bill impacts them
thank you so this would just be possible
future revenue that would be based on
their having come to help us
that's how i interpret the language
any further questions of carolyn lear
mr chairman i'm sorry uh representative
ginagian
yes representative your question thank
you mr chairman i couldn't get to ray's
hand
fast enough um so going back to
representative spilbury's
spielsberg's question um in section 319
d column three um we're moving upon
request by the secretary of state
um that would then mean that the
state of new hampshire would have the
name and so forth of each business
that is um involved and would i guess my
question
um would be would that help
in making sure that revenue was not lost
by being able to account for
who was in the state and who did work i
mean i i realized that
we're trying to minimize the the red
tape
with this bill but i'm just wondering as
i look at this how much red tape it
really would be to give your name
state of domicile and so forth as we
look at sections a through
g or h i'm gonna turn the page here uh
through h it doesn't seem to be an
onerous requirement
to to do that and if that was done
would that help uh revenues
not decrease
thank you for the question
representative i don't that could
certainly be a potentially helpful
compliance tool um but i don't know that
that
overall would impact the revenue outcome
here
registration alone will not under this
bill determine whether
an entity is subject to taxation it is
whether or not they have nexus
and in this instance the bill provides
that for disaster related responses as
outlined in the bill
nexus will not exist and therefore taxes
will not be
owed okay thank you any further
questions
of the dra or mr smith
saying none then i'm going to any uh
is there anybody else in the attendees
list janine
no no there's not then i'm going to
close the public hearing on
senate bill 103. gosh
thank you
that takes care of the public hearings
now tomorrow
starts a new era when we go back to
revenues
i'll be sending out
i believe three spreadsheets this
afternoon
one has to do with the
latest dra estimates that they came up
with
for men and max for their dra type
revenues
another one would be a modified
worksheet at the dr8 that the lba put
together
for us where we generated the revenues
for the house resolution 11
and what i've asked them to do
is to remove those lines on that
worksheet
dealing with the governor minus
mid-range governor minus them estimates
and then put a new line in which will
say
the committee agreed to estimates on
3 18 21
so this will be a working document that
we'll go through
and the third
spreadsheet
is one that puts together
the revenue effect of all the house bill
2 items that affect revenues
that we know about that we went through
the other day
and then have been modified since
so if you review those three that will
help
when we bring the dra in to go over all
their revenues
that'll probably and then uh
that will probably take the whole most
of the first day
the second day we'll bring in those
agencies
that would have been affected by
the economy and what i mean by that
is an effect would be more and more
people
getting vaccinated now so that's going
to have an effect
on maybe a positive effect on worms and
males
the stimulus check the stimulus monies
coming in
and we've got and by that time we'll
know more
what that will do for us and that
will affect our revenues everything
that will affect our revenues up until
the 18th when we come up with our new
revenue estimates
caused by anything we put that that's in
house bill 2
and anything that is caused by the
economy
that will affect the revenues that we
already generated from
hr 11. so we need to accomplish this
over the next two days because the
finance committee needs
our best guesstimates at that point so
they can
do their work and have it done for next
week
any questions on that i'll be sending
you those those three spreadsheets
uh mr chairman yes are you thinking that
the afternoon will be something like one
to three
um
depends on the number of questions and
yeah
oh we perceived i i think
most of our work can be done tomorrow
and then we'll wrap it up
and then what we have to do
on thursday you know today is tuesday
on thursday we should be through
our interrogating in the morning and
then in the afternoon
we'll do our recognizance
thank you so uh mr chairman i think he's
asking because
the democrats have been called to a
caucus starting at three on thursday
and some of our members may stay some of
them may not be able to
feel they can't so
we will be able to discuss
the effects of the federal stimulus and
the vaccines also on
wednesday won't we
i'm hoping too good thank you very much
i'm hoping actually we can get started
on
tomorrow these are so screwed up
today is tuesday so wednesday
yes and thursday we want to
interrogate the other agencies in the
morning
and hopefully exact in the afternoon
we might even be able to do some of our
exactly in the morning on
thursday it depends on
how the information flows
and is that debate thank you questions
or comments
mr
uh is the plan to uh have the controller
and the treasurer first thing tomorrow
morning to deal with the uh
credit card forward issue right the
first thing in the morning
we'll have the controller the treasurer
and the dra so we can
discuss that those lines on the
worksheet that i'm
sending you has to do with
credit carry forward a credit
carry forward issue could be a
is a tough issue it may
force uh delay in that
but before we even do anything we need
to understand
what this really means is it legal what
we've been doing
is a good accounting practice what we've
been doing
and that will determine what action we
need to take after that
but we need to take care of that issue
so then after this all goes away
then we can get to the uh ppp
funds but i i don't want to complicate
things until
we get the revenues for the budgets
spread away
norm do you know if the senate is going
to be voting out that ppp bill pretty
soon
do we know where that stands yeah i only
i only wish they would do the same thing
as they did for the meals and rooms
what they did they voted unanimously
to give the 40 of the meals and rooms
to the towns and then they tabled it and
the reason for tabling is when they get
the bill
bill from us then it gives them an
opportunity to
add it to the budget bill
and uh they may do the same thing with
the pvp
but if they do that we still need to
discuss that and form a position
what you're saying is that bill mr chair
may not come to us
formally
the bill will not come to us formally
right and then they can
they won't have to worry about us
putting it into the
budget and then it would be
settled at the committee of conference
all right but if we've discussed it
ahead of time we have more chance in the
committee of conference
too
okay um anything else
yeah mr chair i have a question uh this
is representative berstein
what bills should we be prepared to
exact
in the coming two days
that's a good question
i don't i'll know tomorrow whether or
not we'll have any time left over on
thursday
to exactly if not then we're going to do
the exact
one the following tuesday
okay thank you mr chairman could i
request
that we not exec after three o'clock on
thursday
you got it you got it thank you
because there's nothing here that can't
wait another week
anything else
all right
early this afternoon you'll be getting
that email from me with those three
spreadsheets
please review them and come prepared
thank you and have a good afternoon